here is the path to the dark side fear
leads to anger anger leads to hate hate
leads to suffering today I want to
discuss with you the different levels of
consciousness and how that can affect
our lives
many years ago I read a book called
power versus force written by David
Hawkins which just so happens to be one
of Wayne Dyer's favorite books as well
as Oprah Winfrey's favorite book and the
first time I read the book it almost
sounded like this and the only reason it
sounded like that wasn't because of the
author it was because the readers level
of consciousness wasn't there yet being
me decided to read the book a couple
times to really understand what the
author was talking about so the book is
really about two things one is the fact
that when we come from a place of force
we divide when we come from a place of
power we bring together and he explains
different levels of consciousness and
which falls on the category of force and
which falls on a category of power and
the author explains the levels from the
lowest level of 20 all the way up to the
highest level of 700 mm a total of 17
levels with the lowest level being
shamed then it's guilt
then it's apathy then it's grief then
it's fear so although fear is higher
than shame guilt apathy and grief it's
still something that immobilizes people
because fear creates a lot of anxiety
and when we're anxious we're afraid of
doing things wrong so we're immobilized
we don't do anything the next level he
talks about is desire now these are he's
talking about desire for alcohol these
are for gambling these are for being
promiscuous these are for those kinds of
things then he goes to level 150 be an
anchor anger is level 150 hate
aggression next level of 175 is pride if
you think about pride being individuals
who don't like others lying to them
where is that stems from that stemmed
from pride because the idea is who are
you to lie to me do you know who I am
it's coming from a place of pride then
level 200 which is you can call it the
equilibrium right in the middle its
courage and the reason why courage is
level 200 because you are finally
willing to put yourself in positions to
be hurt you're willing to put yourself
in positions to maybe make the wrong
decision
maybe your face and your fears you're
overcoming your fears then our next
level goes through neutrality neutrality
is being able to see everybody's issues
and challenges and staying neutral and
still trying to provide some feedback
for them the next level after neutrality
is willingness you are willing to make
things work you are willing to bring
people together you are willing to hear
people's feedback you are willing to
work with people then comes level 350
which is acceptance acceptance is to
understand that people are going to let
you down people are going to make
mistakes and still willing to accept
people and not judge them level 400 is
reason reason where you sit there and
you can hear different issues hear
different challenges hear different
obstacles in a family sitting in a
church in a business and still be able
to bring it together and find ways to
look for solution that's level 400 level
500 is love you know a lot of us ask the
question and say well what was Einstein
which level would an Einstein be
Einstein is level 499 because he was all
about reasoning but he didn't reach the
level of consciousness of love love is
level 500 after love comes level 5 40
which is joy you actually get a chance
to enjoy life at level 5 40 then level
600 is peace in the last level is level
700 which he considers that
enlightenment it's level 7 hundred to a
thousand and he says in the book
currently there are only 12 people alive
that are at level 700 some of the names
you can think about that he talks about
in the book is folks like Buddha he
considers Jesus somebody at the level of
enlightenment right so what can you and
I do with the information he's sharing
here with us well if you think about it
life is all about knowing how to lead
and knowing how to lead is to understand
what level of consciousness we're coming
from as well as what level of
consciousness the people you and I are
leading are coming from so knowing that
and understanding that life is all about
influence we realize that if you and I
can figure out what level were at on
level of consciousness right and being
brutally honest with ourselves what
would happen if you and I were to
increase our levels of consciousness how
can that directly affect your life well
maybe the relationship
we have in our lives we would get better
maybe we would do better with our
business because we're improving as
leaders maybe we do better financially
maybe we would actually be able to enjoy
life
the special people that we have in our
lives if we take the time to improve the
level of consciousness that we have I
want to read an excerpt you from the
book that explains this in the best
possible way it says high states of
consciousness are frequently experienced
by athletes it's widely documented that
long-distance runners frequently attain
sublime states of peace and joy this
very elevation of consciousness in fact
often inspires the prolonged
transcendence of pain and exhaustion
necessary to achieve higher level car
performance this phenomenon is commonly
described in terms of pushing oneself to
the point where one suddenly breaks
through a performance barrier and the
activity becomes effortless the body
then seems to move with grace and ease
of its own accord as though animated by
some invisible force so I think in life
we're always gonna struggle between
power and force but it's important for
you to kind of identify yourself maybe
watch this video again and see where you
rank well where most of your life is all
about and find ways to enhance yourself
on whatever level you may be to enter
power and leave force and if you do that
I can tell you you're gonna experience
some nicer things in life in almost
every aspect of your life if you know
where to identify and how to improve it
that's my message of the week too and
please be sure to subscribe and share
the video
you